[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce
deuxième numéro de si on parlait sport
spécial JO aujourd'hui coûte projecteur
sur les Jeux olympiques de 2024 et plus
particulièrement sur le Golf National de
50 ans en Yvelines qui va accueillir les
épreuves de golf pour parler de cette
thématique nous avons avec nous des
chroniqueurs présentations en musique de
cette magnifique dream team on commence
à ma droite musique il est conseillé
spécial sur les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 à Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines c'est aussi un très grand fan
de golf il répète sans cesse ses gammes
pendant son temps libre et je peux vous
dire que ça paye Mister Jo Arnaud
courtier nous fait l'honneur de venir
dans cette émission comment allez-vous
quoi Arnaud courtier Mister JO c'est ça
on essaye à 50 ans en Yvelines et vous
êtes un passionné de golf absolument
j'ai dans mon téléphone d'ailleurs à une
superbe action que vous avez pu réaliser
récemment au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais
malheureusement la réalisation n'était
pas au rendez-vous donc on ne la montre
pas pour regarde ça se crée on continue
notre tour de table à gauche musique
ladies and gentleman nous avons la
chance d'avoir sur ce plateau le
président de la Fédération Française de
Golf il a œuvré pour la venue de la
Ryder Cup ici sur le Golf National de 50
ans en Yvelines en 2018 et il va
préparer les JO en France en 2024 Mr
présidente Pascal Griso est avec nous
pendant une heure comment allez-vous on
va parler de golf pendant pendant une
heure j'imagine que ça vous ravie je
suis ravi effectivement vous avez révisé
les thématiques j'avoue que j'ai pas
beaucoup révisé ça jamais été ma
spécialité la révision mais j'essaierai
d'être nature on va improviser on
repasse de l'autre côté musique qui nous
vient tout droit du magnifique golf de
national de 50 ans en Yvelines il
travaille depuis 28 ans et 9 mois j'ai
consulté son LinkedIn avant le début de
l'émission et les directeur depuis
juillet 2020 il travaille d'arrache-pied
pour nous préparer des Jeux Olympiques
exceptionnels sur le Golf National
philippidateau nous le bonheur de venir
dans cette émission bonjour comment
allez-vous Philippe merci beaucoup très
très bien c'est à côté vous êtes en
voisin ici oui j'aurais pu venir en vélo
vous avez réalisé vous Pascal patron
très peu très très peu mais j'ai quand
même révisé mes gammes et je vais voir
un petit peu si je peux pas vous excuser
à vous préparer les Jeux olympiques de
2024 qui vont arriver à bientôt on
termine de l'autre côté à musique c'est
une golfeuse professionnelle elle tape
régulièrement des balles sur le Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines mais elle
joue plus régulièrement sur le golf de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye un très beau golf
également la 30 ans allait jouer ce
professionnel Alexandra Bonetti avec
nous pendant une heure comment
allez-vous
donc vous êtes joueuse professionnelle
et vous avez 30 ans c'est bien ça je
suis pas trompé
est-ce que vous avez oui est-ce que vous
avez des anecdotes à nous proposer sur
le Golf National ça commence mais en
effet Philippe on se connaît depuis une
bonne vingtaine d'années
on a eu des parcours qui ont bien évolué
chacun de notre côté mais c'est super
plaisant à chaque fois de retourner au
Golf National 28 ans et 9 mois pour
Philippe Pilato Golf National de 50 ans
en Yvelines si personne ne la croisée
c'est qu'on n'est jamais venu au Golf
National à mon avis alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous parlerons de
la préparation d'un événement comme les
Jeux Olympiques au Golf National de 50
ans en Yvelines on va essayer également
de jouer les Madame Irma et de deviner
quel français représenteront la France
en 2024 aux JO mais avant de parler de
ces thématiques on va parler de
l'histoire de ce golf national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
avant de parler des JO de 2024 il faut
parler avant tout du terrain qui va
accueillir les épreuves de golf on va
parler du Golf National de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines on va refaire l'historique
dès le début des années 80 le nouveau
président de la Fédération Française de
Golf Claude Roger Cartier envisage la
construction d'un site permanent
pourront accueillir les grandes
compétitions notamment l'Open de France
cette Hubert chez snow qui propose un
terrain situé sur le territoire de 50
ans en Yvelines en mai à 86 il esquisses
les plans des deux parcours 18 trous
d'un practice d'un centre d'entraînement
d'un hôtel et du siège de la fédération
française après trois années de travaux
entre 87 et 90 il était inauguré le 5
octobre 1990 depuis 1991 le Golf
National accueille l'Open de France à
l'exception de
parce que le réseau est ce que vous
savez
à l'exception de
99 et 2001 l'Open de France et surtout
il accueille la Ryder Cup en 2018 ça
pour le coup je vous rappelle la date
pour le coup alors une histoire
magnifique cette histoire du Golfe
nationale de 50 ans en Yvelines
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez à Arnaud
courtier j'en pense qu'on a la chance
d'avoir eu à l'époque des gens
visionnaires avec une ambition
incroyable il faut essayer de se
remémorer ce que représenter le golf en
France à l'époque beaucoup moins de
licenciés pas du tout un sport évident
dans notre pays et donc des visionnaires
qui se disent on va construire un
stadium de golf en Île-de-France avec le
rêve d'accueillir un jour la Ryder Cup
qui n'était à l'époque jamais sorti du
continent britannique et Claude Roger
qui militait aussi pour le retour du
golf aux Jeux Olympiques
et l'histoire lui a quand même donné
raison 2018 la Ryder Cup 2024 les jeux
sur ce même parcours c'est
extraordinaire tout simplement le Golf
National magnifique histoire à Philippe
pilatou vous êtes le mieux placé pour
nous en parler peut-être ouais c'est
vrai que c'est une belle histoire et
après ce qui est formidable également
sur sur ce site là c'est que c'est un
golf public c'est l'outil de la
Fédération Française de Golf c'est le
golf comme on le dit souvent c'est le
golf de tous les Français et je pense
que c'est une force également
c'est-à-dire que c'est un site sur
lequel mais voilà tout passionné peut
venir peut marcher comme on le dit
régulièrement dans les traces des
Champions et puis tout le monde peut
venir voilà respirer
tout ce qui est tout ce qui a été fait
et s'imprégner s'imprégner de l'histoire
et tout à fait golf magnifique le Golf
National de 50 ans en Libye parce
qu'elle raison viendrait sur le côté
visionnaire qui a pu avoir Claude Roger
Cartier c'est vrai que des hommes comme
ça ça peut manquer parfois même au plus
haut niveau de l'État avoir des projets
et être capable de se cliquez sur 20 ans
ou sur 30 ans c'est c'est juste
extraordinaire après c'est vrai que
c'est le golf de tous les Français et
c'est vrai que d'autres fédérations ont
également des équipements qui lui
appartiennent que ce soit Clairefontaine
que ce soit Roland-Garros mais la chance
du Golf National c'est que comme la
diffuses c'est un golf qui est ouvert à
tout le monde et effectivement quand on
doit payer pour venir parce qu'il faut
quand même payer un greenfy et c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours tendance quand on
paye à considérer que c'est trop cher
mais de toutes les études comparatives
que l'on fait et on tient absolument à
ce que ça reste le Golf National et de
loin le parcours le bien beaucoup moins
cher de tous les parcours ayant
accueilli des riders Cup donc non
seulement c'est un golf qui est
accessible à tout le monde mais aussi
accessible financièrement Alexandre et
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de ce golf
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je
pensais à l'accessibilité parce que
quand on pense à d'autres terrains qui
ont reçu des riders Cup que ce soit aux
États-Unis ou en Angleterre tout de
suite c'est des budgets énormes ou alors
même des
deadlines pour il faut s'inscrire
vraiment longtemps avant alors que le
golf national on a encore cette chance
de pouvoir l'avoir apporté de demain
entre guillemets et j'ai vu l'évolution
au niveau design un petit peu quand on a
appris qu'on allait recevoir des
événements où il fallait un peu
éclaircir les buts pour le public et
elles sont faites pour ça c'est but
c'est pour accueillir ce public c'est
super un mot sur l'architecte aussi
Hubert chez snow un visionnaire aussi
parce qu'il a créé quand même des
tribunes naturelles c'est ça autour de
chaque trou pour pouvoir accueillir le
maximum de public hein parce qu'elle
réseau il faut dire que Hubert était à
l'époque le directeur général de la de
la fédération et que son premier métier
c'était le métier d'architecte mais
Hubert a aussi été aidé par un des
meilleurs architectes du monde qui
étaient monsieur vanagh et qui a
évidemment
aider Hubert chez nous dans la
conception de ce golf et je pense que
c'est véritablement un travail à quatre
mains parce que Hubert a eu la vision
évidemment avec la sensibilité il avait
il avait déjà construit des parcours de
golf et je pense que le projet a été
encore bonifié grâce aux partenariats
avec Robert vanaghi c'est tribune
naturelle qu'est-ce que vous en pensez à
nos courtiers c'est absolument génial je
pense que ça faisait partie du cahier
des charges j'imagine puisque le but
était d'avoir un stadium et c'est ce qui
nous a permis pour la Ryder Cup d'avoir
autant de public je sais pas si même aux
États-Unis il y avait déjà eu autant de
public sur un parcours de Ryder Cup je
pense même qu'on peut peut-être monter
un peu plus haut en terme de jeu si les
autorités nous nous permettent mais sur
un golf traditionnel plutôt plat dès le
troisième rang de spectateur on voit
plus grand chose alors que là avec les
buts naturels qui forment des gradins
les milliers les dizaines de milliers
spectateurs qui sont là peuvent voir les
parties et même en rider Cup ou le jeu
est plus groupé sur quelques trous
seulement les milliers de spectateurs
peuvent suivre les deux trois parties et
et profiter du jeu donc c'est
extraordinaire c'est phénoménal alors
vous avez pas trop pu voir cette rider
Cup 2018 vous étiez en train de
travailler Philippe Pilato mais les
spectateurs autour de des trous ça fait
des supers images aussi formidable la
seule moment du jeu j'ai pu voir pendant
un rider c'est le dimanche c'était un
peu avant que Nora la remise de la coupe
non mais c'est un peu ça juste quand ça
s'est joué au trou numéro 16 avec
Michaelson qui voilà qui est qui met la
balle dans l'eau et en fait j'avais
vraiment l'impression je me suis mis
dans la tribune du de derrière le 1/18
où il y avait plus de 8000 personnes et
en fait j'avais l'impression d'être
comme si j'étais au Stade de France en
fait parce que en fait il y a ça faisait
vraiment dégrader naturel et j'avais
l'impression de participer à un match de
match de match de golf en gros et c'est
vrai que cette ambiance cette atmosphère
ce chaudron c'était c'était incroyable à
vivre donc c'était le plus formidable je
peux raconter ma vie mais que en terme
d'émotion la pression qu'il lâche après
après une semaine de tournoi et tout ce
monde sur un site qu'on a pas l'habitude
de voir aussi aussi animer c'était
extrêmement fort en émotion oui tout à
fait la Ryder Cup vous avez pu l'avoir
vous Alexandra Bonetti j'ai fait
plusieurs expériences le mardi la
journée d'entraînement où là il y avait
pas encore trop de monde mais du coup
c'était génial le jeudi avec la
cérémonie d'ouverture et encore
l'entraînement alors ça incroyable et le
samedi comme pour quand même faire
l'expérience du jeu et effectivement on
voyait très très bien il y avait pas
besoin d'anticiper 5 3 20 pour se placer
quelque part comme si elle est pour le
Master on sait que souvent choisir tout
pour la journée on bouge plus là
vraiment c'était très agréable
60000 personnes sur cette Ryder Cup par
jour est-ce qu'on aurait pu en
accueillir encore plus ou c'était
vraiment le maximum on aurait pu en
accueillir plus d'abord parce que
d'abord sur le sur le Golf National on
avait la possibilité d'accueillir un
plus grand nombre de spectateurs ça
c'est certain mais surtout aussi grâce
au travail qui avait été fait et
notamment avec la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines où on a
travaillé pendant 10 ans sur un plan de
transport et un plan de transport qui
nous a garanti de pouvoir
acheminer un maximum de spectateurs sans
qu'il y ait jamais aucune tension
ressentie par le spectateur parce que
l'objectif d'une compétition comme ça
c'est d'apporter une expérience du
spectateur et l'expérience du spectateur
elle commence pas quand on est sur le
parcours elle commence à partir du
moment où on quitte chez soi ou on prend
les transports en commun ou on prend sa
voiture on arrive sur les parkings il y
a pas d'embouteillage ensuite on peut
justement les images des personnes qui
qui les supporters qui sont venus
jusqu'au Golf National de
saint-quentin-en-y il y avait des
navettes qui avaient été mises en place
voilà et ensuite ce qui arrivait par le
train ceux qui sont arrivés en voiture
et on voit bien que tout ça c'était
extrêmement fluide donc le travail qui
avait été fourni avant et je le répète
on a eu une aide extrêmement précieuse
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et bien ça
a été la clé du succès et quand on parle
d'expérience souvent quand tu l'as
rappelé mais quand on va dans de grands
championnats de golf et bien on se met à
un spot et puis on voit le même coup
pendant toute la journée moi vous avez
fait le calcul quand on se mettait à la
fin du Green du numéro 1 par exemple le
matin il y avait quatre groupes qui
partaient ça faisait à peu près une
heure et demie entre le 1 et le 2 1h30
c'est le temps d'un terrain de foot sauf
que quand le foot le match de foot est
terminé on rentre chez soi là on passait
au trou numéro 8 9 10 et encore c'était
de nouveau encore un endroit où on
pouvait suivre trois parties afin trois
trous en même temps et après on allait
sur le 15 16 17 et c'était encore la
même chose donc c'est vrai qu'en termes
d'expérience pour le spectateur c'était
vraiment une compétition qui était qui
était unique c'est rare ou pas de
d'avoir ça sur un sur un golf alors
le parcours de Phoenix par exemple ou il
y a 200 000 spectateurs donc là c'est
encore évidemment beaucoup plus
important mais quand on parle de 200 000
c'est pas 200 000 qui rentrent sur le
parcours c'est 200000 qui sont dans la
ville de Phoenix et qui fait ce grand
tournoi et vous avez un amphithéâtre qui
est l'amphithéâtre du trou numéro 16 le
par 3 ou là vous avez à peu près
personnes mais nous autour du 1 et du 2
on avait déjà 40000 personnes donc
c'était aussi très impressionnant on va
parler maintenant de la difficulté de ce
golf national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est-ce qu'il
est si difficile que ça Alexandra alors
la première vue il peut ne pas l'être ne
pas paraître dur mais en fait les rêves
sont très très denses et on peut se dire
on sort facilement avec un fer
modérément fermé en fait non non souvent
les amateurs en tout cas qui n'ont pas
les avant-bras de Paul Kessy doivent
vraiment
abdiquer et se recentrer sur le faire
avant de pouvoir essayer de d'attaquer
de nouveau mais donc il y a ça les Green
si on les met rapide peuvent être très
très vaste diabolique si on connaît pas
les nombreuses pentes et ensuite le
tracé et s'il rétrécit également les
fairway ça peut être très intéressant
j'ai demandé à une professionnelle
maintenant un amateur qui le pratique de
temps en temps Arnaud courtier alors
est-ce qu'il est difficile oui surtout
pour l'amateur que je suis mais on le
sait vous pouvez voter si vous voulez
oui non on l'aborde avec beaucoup
d'humilité mais beaucoup de plaisir
parce qu'il est difficile qu'on l'a joué
deux trois fois on sait comment
théoriquement il faut le jouer il faut
pas y aller et voilà c'est ça vous ouvre
mais on sait aussi surtout qu'on a la
chance de jouer sur un parcours de
championnat international qui
accueillent la Ryder Cup qui va
accueillir les Jeux qui a eu les
meilleurs joueurs du monde et on est au
même endroit que c'est ça aussi qui est
extraordinaire qu'on parlait d'autres
sports moi je peux pas aller jouer au
foot au Parc des Princes au Stade de
France je peux difficilement aller faire
une partie de tennis Roland Garros par
contre je peux aller tous les jours
jouer au golf national ça c'est
extraordinaire sur le même terrain que
les champions Philippe très difficile ce
golf national de 50 ans
majeures d'un joueur de golf c'est
l'humidité je pense que c'est un
parcours qu'il faut jouer avec humilité
c'est un parcours qu'il faut il faut
prendre ce qu'il donne mais il faut pas
il faut pas il faut pas aller le
chercher en gros c'est séduit c'est lui
qui vous permettra voilà d'avoir un bon
score à l'issue je pense que ce qui est
important c'est de c'est la mise en jeu
effectivement comme le disait Alexandra
et après derrière c'est on a fait en
préparation de la rider Cup de une
grosse amélioration au niveau des
grilles avec des Green qui maintenant
sont extrêmement fermes et donc après
c'est une autre difficulté pour le
joueur amateur de faire garder de garder
une balle sur les Grimes c'est dur quand
on peut les avoir actuellement confiance
un peu c'est un peu compliqué donc voilà
je pense que c'est l'humidité et puis
voilà et puis de jouer le jouer le jouer
avec des bonnes mises en jeu la météo
aussi est un peu capricieuse aussi
allez-y deux choses qui sont
essentielles au golf national c'est que
d'abord un vous avez des obstacles des
obstacles d'eau vous avez 10 obstacles
d'eau qui sont en jeu sur 10 trous sur
18 et quand vous mettez la balle dans
l'eau c'est pas un point que ça coûte le
mauvais coup c'est deux et souvent ça
peut en coûter 3 donc l'erreur au golf
national elle coûte beaucoup plus cher
et pour
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur en tout
cas à l'erreur elle coûte effectivement
plus cher et le Golf National aussi on
compare souvent des pistes rouges les
pistes noires mais le Golf National ça
peut pas correspondre à une piste c'est
plutôt un ORPI c'est comme si vous
faites faisiez une face nord de belcôte
vous voyez dans les Alpes c'est c'est ça
c'est c'est hors catégorie et c'est très
difficile d'aller comparer le golf
national avec un autre parcours en
France on a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
de parcours mais un parcours qui est
aussi sélectif le jour où vous jouez
très bien et on l'a vu au championnat du
monde amateur il y a des joueurs qui ont
très très bien joué qui ont fait des
journées fantastiques et qu'on jouait
600 sous et puis la même journée le
dimanche les conditions sont un tout
petit peu plus compliquées il y a un
petit peu plus de pression et les 6 en
dessous se termine en 4 ou 5 au dessus
donc il peut y avoir des variations de
score sur ce parcours qui sont énormes
et qu'on retrouve pas sur d'autres
parcours moi ce qui marque aussi c'est
la météo aussi qui est parfois
capricieuse avec notamment le vent qui
qui joue beaucoup
Philippe ventilateur
qu'il faut qu'on écoute non mais c'est
vrai que c'est un plateau et qui est pas
protégé et les paysans les paysans du
coin donc je les ai pas connus à
l'époque même ça fait longtemps que je
suis allé je sais pas si ça et ils
disent que c'est voilà la Petite Sibérie
parce que c'est vrai que l'hiver il fait
un peu froid et puis c'est pas protégé
c'est pas protégé par le vent donc dans
dans voilà donc c'est vrai que la météo
est quand même importante et en
complément de ce que disait Pascal aussi
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a pas de trou
sur lequel on peut se reposer en fait il
y a pas un trou sur lequel on peut se
dire bon monsieur là je veux jouer enfin
des tous les trous sont vraiment
exigeants donc dès l'instant on tape la
balouin et qu'on arrive au 18 il faut
être faut être concentré je vais vous
demander maintenant de vous mouiller une
question un peu cruciale sur cette
thématique le Golf National est-il le
plus beau de France oui vers rouge non
on va vous faire un petit duel peut-être
entre vous Alexandra et Philippe qui va
défendre son golf
Alexandra pourquoi alors non mais la
beauté on sait très bien que c'est très
vaste et que du coup il y a beaucoup de
parents
non mais du point de vue esthétique j'ai
une attirance pour l'école avec des pins
qu'on trouve dans les Landes dans le
nord de Paris etc je donnerai pas de nom
que ça je vais pas me le golf peut-être
de Saint-Germain peut-être aussi qui est
dans les Yvelines on a les images du
golf de Saint-Germain ou rouge
et donc esthétiquement tout de suite ça
me fait plus quelque chose mais ça c'est
pour le côté juste spectateur pour le
côté joueur là effectivement quand
j'arrive au 1 même 15 ans après je
prends toujours une photo quand il y a
le soleil qui se reflète sur le lac
entre le 1 et le 2 donc bien sûr ça me
fait quelque chose mais voilà si on
parle beauté c'est très subjectif
Philippe Pilato
encore moi je trouve formidable parce
que
[Rires]
je trouve formidable c'est ce que disait
Alexandra c'est que l'avantage et la
beauté de ce golf c'est que quand on est
sur un trou on est sur le trou c'est à
dire qu'en fait il y a rien à côté qui
qui peut distraire et je trouve qu'on
est qu'on est complètement absorbé par
par la situation de jeu et par le trou
sur lequel on est en train de jouer et
moi ce que je trouve beau et c'est vrai
qu'après derrière il y a des périodes
matin c'est incroyable le site le soir
c'est incroyable la journée quand il y a
c'est c'est c'est incroyable aussi mais
c'est vrai qu'avec les lumières lumière
rasante le site moi je le trouve enfin
bon voilà ça fait mon j'y suis et je
suis toujours émerveillé par la beauté
mais je suis peut-être pas suffisamment
du spectateur et du joueur on a parlé de
ce côté Stadium quand on est sur le
fairway qu'on joue on n'a pas du tout la
même vision que quand on est spectateur
en hauteur et qu'on regarde et pour le
spectateur il est particulièrement beau
quand il y a un open quand il y a un
grand événement parce que finalement il
y a du monde il y a les hospitalités les
tentes et ça ça abîme ce golf mais
j'aime beaucoup d'autres parcours aussi
mais c'est en fait c'est un des plus
beaux parcours de France mais
définitivement
et Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc voilà ça
va vous tombez bien un dernier mot sur
ce golf national de 50 ans en Libye
peut-être votre meilleur souvenir sur le
Golf National on va faire un petit tour
de table Pascal peut-être on commence
par vous votre meilleur souvenir mon
meilleur souvenir c'est c'est
certainement la fin de la Ryder Cup un
grand moment de soulagement
que tout s'est bien passé et que ben
voilà on a délivré un événement qui
était à la hauteur des attentes de tout
le monde que ce soit les joueurs en
premier parce que c'est évidemment les
premiers concernés mais évidemment les
partenaires qui nous ont accompagnés
pendant toutes ces années et puis les
détenteurs de droits et c'est vrai c'est
pas nous qui l'avons dit c'est eux qui
l'ont dit que la Ryder Cup 2018 était
certainement la plus belle des riders
comme jamais organisé donc oui ça fait
plaisir et voilà et quand tout se
termine bien
euh ben c'est un vrai soulagement
Alexandra votre meilleur souvenir en
tant que spectatrice il y a pas photo
c'est rider Cup également mais en tant
que joueuse on avait eu la chance
d'avoir les championnats d'Europe dame
en 2007 et j'avais eu une invitation
parce que j'étais membre du Golf
National et c'est quelque chose ou voilà
où j'ai bien performé le meilleur
souvenir voilà c'était super bien
Philippe moi c'est avant la rider et
c'est c'était l'accueil de Jim Fury et
il était accompagné de de six joueurs
qui venaient reconnaître le parcours il
y avait Jordan Spice il y avait il y
avait il y avait Tony finale et ce
moment là était incroyable parce que
femme personnellement j'ai les ressenti
comme comme le voilà ça y est on y est
c'est le lancement la rider c'est là
c'est demain ils sont là et c'est du
concret c'est du c'est du réel et ce
moment là était tout simplement magique
voilà tu es peut-être le dernier moment
vous avez vu réellement la Ryder Cup
jusqu'à la fin
la chance de les suivre pendant la
journée les deux jours sur lesquels ils
étaient là et c'était c'était ça aussi
c'était le moment du moment incroyable
inoubliables
alors moi mon meilleur souvenir c'est le
premier jour de la Ryder Cup pour tout
petit matin il faisait pas le jour
j'étais tout en haut de la tribune du 1
qui était déjà pleine et le jeu
commençais pas tout de suite il disait
encore nuit et envoyer les gens
arrivaient en courant pour prendre des
places et on se pinçait en se disant on
est en France on est au Gold ça démarre
ça y est et on voit des gens arriver à
6h du matin en courant sur le golf
on en avait rêvé ça se concrétiser voilà
c'est extraordinaire
alors on l'a dit le golf national va
accueillir les Jeux olympiques de 2024
après la Ryder Cup aucun parcours ne l'a
fait au monde si je me trompe pas c'est
une chance incroyable pour le site c'est
notre deuxième thématique c'est notre
deuxième question les JO de 2024
sont-ils aussi grands que la Ryder Cup
oui ou non ou voter
aussi grand
partager non pour vous
Alexandra partager aussi bon vu que
c'est Pascal qui a voté en premier
Pascal pourquoi
[Musique]
les Jeux olympiques sont un événement
extraordinaire extraordinaire qui je
pense est le plus grand événement
sportif au monde après l'édition golf
dans le cadre des Jeux Olympiques c'est
pas le plus grand événement de golf de
l'année on a la chance d'avoir quatre
tournois majeurs historiques qui
existent depuis des dizaines d'années et
qui sont très au dessus en termes même
de
d'envie pour le spectateur de de suivre
ces tournois là et la Ryder Cup c'est en
quelque chose d'encore complètement
spécial parce que tous les tournois
majeurs d'abord se jouent sur le même
format le même format de jeu la Ryder
Cup c'est un format de match play en
plus de ça c'est beaucoup plus clivant
vous avez l'Europe et les États-Unis
quand vous un tournoi de golf
généralement vous ne supportez un joueur
de joueur 3 joueurs là vous soutenez une
équipe contre une autre équipe et il y a
une émulation juste incroyable et
l'ambiance qui a dans une rider Cup on
ne la retrouve dans aucun autre tournoi
au monde et c'est injuste de comparer
les deux parce que la Ryder Cup a
beaucoup d'avance sur le golf aux Jeux
Olympiques ça on en est à la deuxième
édition et j'espère que dans 100 ans on
se dira que oui les Jeux Olympiques
c'est un des plus grands événements de
golf au monde mais pour l'instant il
faut être objectif c'est pas le cas
Philippe vous avez voté moi je suis
partagé parce que alors ça sera
certainement pas aussi grand pour les
raisons énoncées par Pascal par contre
c'est la première fois que on va vivre
un événement en faisant partie d'un
ensemble et dans tout c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait on va y avoir sont les Jeux
Olympiques donc c'est extrêmement fort
et je pense que ça va être également une
force parce que ça va amener ça va
permettre de mettre peut-être en avant
également mais le site Le Golf National
le parcours le parcours le parcours le
parcours l'Albatros et je pense que pour
nous c'est une vraie force et je pense
que les JO ils vont être forts en termes
d'événements ciel et fort en termes de
rencontres également donc voilà c'est
pour ça que je le placerai à ce
niveau-là vous êtes d'accord avec
Philippe j'imagine avec Pascal d'avoir
les jeux au Golf National ça va
justement contribuer à alimenter
l'histoire du golf aux Jeux Olympiques
puisqu'effectivement c'est une histoire
qui a redémarré il y a peu de temps à
Rio en 2016 le golf a été longtemps
absent des jeux le golf c'est c'est de
l'histoire la Ryder Cup c'est historique
c'est depuis longtemps il faut
reconstruire l'histoire du golf aux Jeux
olympiques et le fait que les jeux cette
année soit sur ce parcours là qui est
extraordinaire qui a déjà accueilli la
Ryder Cup une édition extraordinaire
aussi ça va je pense être un point très
positif pour les Jeux Olympiques
justement avec c'est indéniable le monde
entier qui regarde cet événement des
gens du monde entier qui vont venir qui
vont découvrir le site donc c'est c'est
très positif mais
mais je sais que tous les golfeurs
notamment Céline Antoine Rosner etc
participer à la cérémonie d'ouverture et
rencontrer des athlètes d'autres sports
pour eux c'est un moment inoubliable en
fait donc effectivement ça n'a pas la
portée d'une rider Cup dans le monde du
Golfe mais pour un passionné de sport
c'est unique vous êtes d'accord avec
Alexandra ce que je disais tout à
l'heure je vais peut-être mal dit mais
c'était un petit peu ça c'est
effectivement le fait de voilà de
participer à un événement golfique dans
un dans un ensemble et je pense que ça
c'est une vraie force c'est quand on
voit en plus les champions qui l'ont
gagné alors je sais pas si ça fera
partie du quiz donc je donnerai pas les
réponses mais
effectivement il y a peut-être une
question de je suis on verra
donc voilà on voit vraiment envie de
gagner hein je vous précise ce sont des
joueurs sont des joueurs qui voilà qui
est qui sont encore présents qui marque
le golf qui vont le marquer parce qu'ils
vont certainement de gagner de mon corps
des tournois majeurs et au niveau 8 des
golfeurs enfin on pense au tennis aussi
c'est un petit peu la même dynamique on
va dire ils ont des tournois toute
l'année les tennisman et tous les quatre
ans ils ont aussi cette participation
aux Jeux olympiques et Djokovic par
exemple n'a jamais gagné n'a jamais
gagné de médailles d'or aux Jeux
Olympiques c'est un peu le regret de sa
carrière est-ce que pour un golfeur ça
peut être un peu la même chose ou pas
est-ce que c'est tous les quatre ans je
sais pas c'est vraiment la deuxième
édition et
et c'est encore un c'est encore un petit
peu tôt mais je pense que de toute façon
mais ça c'est plus Alexandra qu'il faut
le demander c'est que ces joueurs là
quand ils se plantent le tille au départ
c'est c'est pas pour faire de la
figuration donc que ce soit les Jeux
olympiques ou que ce soit un autre
tournoi à partir du moment où ils ont
décidé de d'y participer c'est rare que
ce soit pas pour gagner en tout cas les
meilleurs c'est les meilleurs c'est
comme ça après je pense qu'il y a une
envie de vouloir marquer l'histoire mais
je pense quand même que les tournois
majeurs ont encore une importance
supérieure Tiger Woods qui n'a jamais
joué les Jeux Olympiques pourraient être
présent à votre avis en 2024 avec Tiger
Wood on peut jamais faire de prévision
donc moi vous m'auriez demandé six mois
avant la Ryder Cup si il allait à la
Ryder Cup j'aurais certainement répondu
par la négative et si vous m'aviez dit
après la Ryder Cup est-ce qu'il serait
capable de regagner un tournoi majeur
j'aurais mis tout mon argent de poche
sur sur
le premier tournoi majeur au master six
mois après donc avec Tiger Woods là je
pense qu'on a à faire un tel champion
qui sort des normes que voilà c'est
humilité dans la réponse et il y a que
lui qui la connaît au niveau des
audiences est-ce que vous savez parce
qu'elle réseau combien il y a de
personnes qui ont regardé les Jeux
Olympiques les derniers Jeux Olympiques
pas du tout ça fait partie
justement c'est pour ça la question non
non j'ai pas d'idées et si vous laissez
ça c'est que la Ryder Cup ça a été le
monde du golf s'arrête pendant trois
jours parce que toutes les télés du
monde sont branchés sur la Ryder Cup là
et c'est aussi le grand honneur pour la
France de recevoir les jeux c'est que il
va pas y avoir que le golf et il va y
avoir beaucoup d'autres beaucoup
d'autres
compétitions sportives et moi ma crainte
c'est que le golf ne soit pas exposé à
sa juste valeur donc on verra ce que ça
donne au moment où
ces jeux seront organisés mais c'est
très clairement ma crainte alors que
j'avais pas cette crainte là pour la
Ryder Cup moi je savais pertinemment que
le jour où on vendrait les billets et
bien on serait en sold out au bout d'une
heure et c'est ce qui s'est passé alors
on va maintenant passer de notre
troisième thématique l'organisation
pendant les Jeux olympiques de 2024 au
Golf National de 50 ans en ligne on
attend plusieurs milliers de spectateurs
sur le site on attend aussi à des
bénévoles dans cette thématique on va
voir comment se prépare le Golf National
la question sur cette thématique elle
est adressée principalement à vous à
Philippe Pilato est-ce que le Golf
National est-il déjà prêt pour 2024
je pense que je pense que le parcours en
lui-même fasse il faut que je vote voilà
partager je pense que le site en
lui-même le parcours ne va pas avoir il
va pas y avoir de modifications majeure
c'est-à-dire que le parcours qu'on a que
vous allez pouvoir jouer demain qu'un
joueur va jouer demain ça sera
exactement le le même parcours que pour
les les Jaux acceptés en termes de en
termes d'exigence c'est-à-dire qu'on va
on va travailler de façon à rendre le
parcours mais plus sélectif plus voilà
plus à la hauteur il faut les il faut
les gagner à la médaille
on commence à travailler avec avec
l'agronome en charge de la préparation
du parcours donc on a on va commencer
les réunions toutes les trois semaines
justement et vraiment le focus avec le
super intendant du Golf National qui est
Monsieur Lucas Pierret et qui a prouvé
qui a prouvé qui voilà qui qui pouvait
sortir en parcours de très bonne qualité
lors des différents championnats qu'on
avait pu accueillir c'est de ça va être
de commencer à travailler à préparer à
préparer le parcours de façon à ce que
lorsque le le premier joueur plantera
son petit au départ du 1 il soit dans
les dans les normes exigées par par le
PGA tours et puis par Paris 2024 et tout
sera prêt quand à peu près vous savez
moi je pense que là de toute façon là
maintenant on commence à le travailler
là maintenant et il sera prêt je pense
je pense qu'il sera prêt au moins un
mois avant l'événement un mois avant
l'événement oui tout à fait parce que le
Golf National est prêt à accueillir cet
événement je vous dis il est prêt alors
Philippe lui est beaucoup plus prudent
mais moi je vous dis qu'il est prêt de
même que déjà aujourd'hui il est prêt
aujourd'hui parce que si demain on
devait organiser la Ryder Cup la Ryder
Cup les Jeux Olympiques il y aurait très
très peu de modifications à faire et
vous savez il y a des exigences de ce
que veulent les organisateurs mais j'ai
eu la chance moi pendant la préparation
de la Ryder Cup d'être sur les parcours
des tournois majeurs et d'être sur les
parcours de la Ryder Cup et j'ai jamais
vu aucun autre parcours aussi bien
préparé que celui de la Ryder Cup en
2018 et les un homme qui nous
accompagnait pour la préparation du
parcours c'est pas nous qui l'avons dit
ont déclaré que un an avant la Ryder Cup
on aurait parfaitement déjà pu jouer le
rider Cup donc moi je fais confiance à
nos équipes qui ont une expérience
incroyable parce que comme on l'a dit
c'est le seul parcours au monde qui va
avoir ce pedigree qui aura reçu son open
national pendant 30 ans qui aura reçu la
Ryder Cup qui aura reçu les Jeux
Olympiques et puis on a quand même reçu
aussi l'année dernière les championnats
du monde qui est une compétition très
exigeante qui se déroule sur deux
semaines et là encore les équipes ont
démontré leur savoir-faire et leurs
compétences pour préparer un parcours à
ce niveau là donc personnellement j'ai
aucune inquiétude non j'ai pas
d'inquiétude pour ça non Alexandre
est-ce qu'il sera prêt ce parcours
je pense qu'on a eu tellement de
répétitions maintenant de de qualité
exceptionnelle que là on est prêt et
puis maintenant c'est je pense qu'il est
temps que ça arrive maintenant on
l'attend il y aura combien de personnes
sur le site vous savez ou pas à nos
courtiers alors à prier sur le sur le
dossier
spectateurs par jour pour la rider
exactement avec un tournoi masculin un
tournoi féminin donc deux fois quatre
jours par rapport à la préparation moi
je vous dirais qu'on est en test Steven
depuis 1991 donc il y a un savoir-faire
qui s'est développé avec les équipes et
avec les événements qui ont été
accueillis donc le parcours évidemment
le site est prêt et puis pour
l'événement il y a tout ce qui vient se
greffer pour la queue du public pour la
sécurité pour l'hospitalité pour les
transports autour voilà mais tout ça va
se mettre en place
naturellement c'est le travail avec le
comité d'organisation des Jeux avec la
Fédération bien sûr avec le territoire
mais ce site est finalement aujourd'hui
prêt par optiez lever mes presque à
accueillir des grands événements
internationaux parce que le standard du
site est exceptionnel il y a comment
s'organise au niveau peut-être des
transports aussi on l'a vu ça c'est très
bien déroulé pendant la Ryder Cup on
bosse déjà dessus à la GO de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ah oui on
travaille dessus et puis depuis un petit
moment déjà on va être un petit peu
comme pour la Ryder Cup avec des quais
de gare routière éphé déjà installé dans
le centre de Saint-Quentin à proximité
de la gare ferroviaire pour avoir des
navettes qui vont desservir les quatre
sites olympiques le vélodrome le Stadium
BMX la colline pour le VTT et le Golf
National tout le centre de 50 ans les
mines sera mis en place pour
la multiplicité des sites et des
compétitions fait que nous allons avoir
des compétitions quasiment tous les
jours pendant les 15 jours des Jeux donc
un flux de spectateurs permanent donc le
territoire va être très animé ça et ça
c'est super et du golf les deux semaines
donc c'est merveilleux et pareil au
niveau de la circulation ça devrait être
fluide selon vous parce que là pendant
la Ryder Cup je vous l'avoue j'ai jamais
vu 50 ans et demi dans cet état là au
niveau des routes ça c'est très très
bien passé aucun embouteillage il faut
être honnête il y a eu un super travail
de fait avec tout le monde avec les
organisateurs de la Ryder Cup avec avec
l'État avec des navettes on a la chance
d'avoir des grands axes à Saint-Quentin
c'est formidable des des des voix
dédiées aux transports en commun donc ça
sera la même chose pendant les Jeux
Olympiques
en plus qu'on sera sur une période de
vacances quand même il y aura peut-être
un peu moins de monde qui présentent sur
le territoire mais donc oui ce sera
fluide aucun souci pour ça aucune
inquiétude et comment ça va se passer au
niveau des des bénévoles je crois que
vous bossez aussi sur le dossier à nos
courtiers pas de sport et pas de grands
événements sans les bénévoles il y aura
beaucoup de bénévoles je rappelle un
petit chiffre intéressant les Jeux
Olympiques qui recrutent 45000 bénévoles
à peu près donc c'est incroyable donc
des bénévoles dans le programme
olympique sur les sites olympiques et en
complément de ça un programme de
bénévoles du territoire pour justement
gérer l'accueil du public
accueillir les touristes les guider et
plein de choses et puis on travaille à
certains projets je peux pas encore
parler de tout mais pour avoir aussi
peut-être des lieux festifs pour la
population pour pour les fans de sport
et qui nécessiteront aussi bien sûr
l'aide des bénévoles pour encadrer tout
ça c'est complet ou pas pour devenir
bénévole non non c'est pas grave ça se
passe comment alors soit en candidature
pour le programme de Paris 2024 via le
site de paris 2024 soit en candidature
pour le Programme des bénévoles du
territoire sur le site de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sqy.fr
Alexandra bénévole peut-être sur ces
Jeux Olympiques
spectatrice
et même un objectif de participer bon là
ça semble c'est un petit à petit mais
j'avais gravé sur mes wedge les anneaux
olympiques donc bénévole non ça même au
quotidien sur un petit tournoi de niveau
français européen on a toujours besoin
de bénévoles donc là la masse est bien
sûr décuplée mais mais j'espère qu'ils
seront nombreux à répondre présent les
bénévoles aussi indispensables mais oui
alors là aussi c'est pareil on a on a un
réseau de bénévoles sur lequel la
Fédération peut compter depuis longtemps
avec l'organisation de l'Open de France
on a vu le cas aussi pour la Ryder Cup
et ce sera exactement la même chose pour
les pour les Jeux Olympiques c'est vrai
qu'il faut un savoir-faire parce que les
bénévoles qui sont utilisés et choisis
sur les épreuves de golf doivent avoir
une véritable formation et cette
formation ils ont eu la chance de de
d'avoir pu l'acquérir au fil des
tournois que de la Fédération organisée
alors côté donc là aussi pas de pas de
problème oui à 50 ans on voit souvent
les mêmes bénévoles qui reviennent à
chaque fois sur sur tous les événements
on peut dire qu'ils sont rodéo moi
professionnels
des grands événements sportifs sur le
territoire et on a des bénévoles
spécialisés golf spécialisés cyclisme
sur piste parce qu'effectivement il y a
des techniques bien particulières des
gens qui sont heureux d'être présents
nous aider et on les remercie parce que
sans eux on pourrait pas faire tout ça
mais oui on les on les connaît bien ils
nous connaissent bien et on travaille
avec eux toute l'année et ils sont là je
tiens à dire aussi c'est important pour
les grands et pour les petits événements
ils sont là pour une Ryder Cup pour un
champion du monde de ces game sur piste
mais ils sont là quand le week-end on
fait des journées découvertes avec les
enfants ils sont présents qui peuvent
qui vendent qui nage donc voilà c'est
super important de les avoir une petite
pensée pour les deux Jean-Paul en conçu
qu'on voit sur tous les événements
justement à Arnaud courtier Jean-Paul 1
et Jean-Paul II c'est comme ça qui
s'appelle et on les voit on les voit sur
tous les événements et ils sont toujours
présents que ce soit des petits
événements ou des gros événements alors
on va maintenant parler des golfeurs
français qui pourrait fouler le Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines je vous
rappelle les règles il devrait y avoir
deux Français et deux français
sélectionnés d'office pour les épreuves
de golf mais qui sera là je vais vous
proposer un petit panel et vous allez me
dire si oui ou non vous les voyez aux JO
de 2024 alors on va commencer par
Antoine rosener le versaillé de 29 ans a
notamment gagné le Qatar master en 2021
il a gagné récemment en Mauritus Open et
ce qu'il peut faire les Jeux Olympiques
Antoine Rosner oui ou non
nouveauté
et est-ce qu'il y sera votre avis
oui aussi Pascal
garçon qui qui joue très bien maintenant
c'est vrai que les places sont ouvertes
chez les garçons parce que on a la
chance on parlera des filles d'avoir une
fille qui aujourd'hui est très au-dessus
du lot mais chez les garçons ça se
bagarre donc
ça peut encore beaucoup changé mais on
l'a vu en fin de saison
on a encore fait une très bonne
performance il est jeune il s'entraîne
il en a toujours envie de gagner donc je
je pense que logiquement il devrait
faire partie de ces équipes là mais de
cette équipe mais attention parce que
derrière ça pousse aussi il peut y avoir
des blessures aussi on ne sait jamais ça
c'est ce que je veux surtout pas leur
souhaiter en tout cas sur le papier vous
le voyez aux JO 2024 Alexandra est-ce
que vous le voyez aux JO de 2024 en plus
il sera à domicile hein
presque à domicile
des centaines de fois le golf national
il a participé à Tokyo
2020-2021 mais par contre sans toute
l'euphorie et sans sa famille sans rien
du tout en fait donc je pense qu'il a
très à coeur de revivre des Jeux
Olympiques en conditions plus normale
avec toute sa famille sur place
de nombreuses années exactement on a la
chance de le voir régulièrement Antoine
parce que au-delà d'être un grand
champion c'est c'est une belle personne
donc je lui souhaite voilà d'être de
planter le tir au départ du Maroc
oui on lui souhaite en plus voilà et
mais c'est ouvert ça pousse il y a du il
y a du monde alors chez les filles on en
parlait précédemment je pense que vous
vouliez l'évoquer Céline Boutier que
vous connaissez très bien Alexandra
Bonetti est-ce qu'on peut voir peut-être
la photo d'Alexandra Bonetti je sais pas
si c'est possible en régie la photo
d'Alexandra Bonetti avec Céline Boutier
donc vous la connaissez très bien comme
on peut on peut le voir c'est une
boutique ce qu'elle sera aux JO c'est
quasi sûr à 100%
voilà comme vous disiez c'était juste la
blessure qui peut changer le le contexte
elle est exceptionnelle elle a une
éthique de travail qui elle est très
très discrète en fait donc les gens
réalisent pas la charge de travail qui
est derrière parce qu'elle aime pas être
mise en valeur mais
trop partagé en fait non plus elle est
secrète mais ça tous les grands
champions vont leur secret et en fait
elle est elle a son entourage très
proche qui la met à l'aise et elle
s'épanouit et elle l'excelle là-dedans
et puis elle est que 12e mondiale donc
elle a encore 11 place à chercher et
elle va continuer
vous êtes fans
de la personne je suis fan de de ce
qu'elle représente
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
beaucoup parler de Céline Pascal en
parlait lors d'une réunion c'est une
joueuse qu'il faut qu'il faut réellement
voilà il faut qu'on partage il faut
qu'on parle d'elle parce que elle est
elle est là elle est elle est en haut du
en 12e place mondiale et elle a vraiment
le potentiel pour aller beaucoup plus
loin donc oui j'espère enfin oui elle
sera au départ du Henri
ils ont tout dit on a la chance d'avoir
une jeune joueuse talentueuse
travailleuse
exactement et une carrière c'est mon
golf et il y a encore des places à aller
chercher je suis pas le mieux placé pour
juger je suis pas un expert mais moi
déjà je suis très heureux et très fier
en tant que Français de voir cette jeune
française qui fait qui performe au plus
haut niveau mondial tout simplement
qu'est-ce qui vous impressionne le plus
parce que le réseau c'est une boutique
Céline c'est peut-être parmi les
joueuses françaises celles que je
connais le mieux parce que on se parle
très souvent quand elle vient on joue
ensemble on partage des des parties et
et mon objectif moi quand j'ai été élu
président de la Fédération c'était de
d'arriver à faire quelque chose qu'on
n'a jamais réussi à faire et c'est un
petit peu l'échange que je me lance à
chaque fois mais même si ça ne revient
que au talent grâce au talent de nos
athlètes moi mon objectif c'est d'avoir
des athlètes qui font partie des 20
meilleurs joueurs du monde parce que
quand vous êtes au-delà des 20 meilleurs
joueurs du monde vous pouvez gagner un
tournoi majeur mais c'est la pièce que
vous jetez en l'air et on s'aperçoit que
ceux qui gagnent régulièrement ces
tournois là ce sont des joueurs et des
joueuses qui font partie des 20
meilleurs joueurs du monde et elle et
12e et ça c'est l'objectif de la
fédération de placer des joueurs et des
joueuses donc on a au moins réussi cet
objectif pour l'instant chez les femmes
avec Céline encore une fois la
Fédération l'a aidé elle a fait partie
des pôles quand elle était plus jeune et
qu'elle était amateur la Fédération l'a
aidé est suivie mais le talent c'est
elle et les clubs en main c'est elle
donc c'est performances elles ne le doit
qu'elle mais moi ce que j'admire surtout
chez elle c'est sa capacité de travail
et sa résilience qu'elle peut qu'elle
peut avoir cette remise en question
aussi parce que c'était une joueuse qui
tapait pas forcément le plus fort et
puis on voyait bien moi quand je la vois
on voit rarement des joueuses françaises
à la télé mais quand on voyait on voyait
bien que par rapport aux meilleurs
joueuses elle était plus courte elle
avait du mal à toucher les par 52 et moi
je joue avec elle Simon après et on a
mon âge et on a à peu près la même
distance et je vois qu'elle avait pris
10 mètres 15 mètres sur le Drive et ça
c'est très rare pour des joueurs d'être
capable d'arriver à faire ça et derrière
tout ça comme l'a dit Alexandra c'est
pas juste qu'un matin elle s'est
réveillé en se disant il faut que je
tape plus fort il y a énormément de
travail derrière pour arriver à cet
objectif là et ça suit dans les
résultats parce que il y a deux ans elle
était 30e elle est passée 25e 20e et là
elle est 12e en ayant fait toute l'année
dans les 20 meilleurs joueuses du monde
c'est juste exceptionnel on va parler
maintenant d'une autre féminine Pauline
Roussin Bouchard à la 22 ans elle est
très prometteuse sera-t-elle aux JO
selon vous oui ou non allez on va dire
oui pour vous Pascal oui tout le monde
une anime aussi qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez d'avoir une joueuse comme Perrine
là qui ce qui levait un petit peu le
pied et qui s'entraîne au golf national
pour l'instant et qui passe des diplômes
au golf national mais je pense que si
elle a pris un peu de recul c'est pour
repartir plus fort aussi et c'est une
joueuse qui a beaucoup de de qualité et
qui est parfaitement capable de faire
comme elle l'a déjà fait partie de
l'équipe olympique alors c'est sûr que
Pauline elle a un potentiel incroyable
comme Céline elle a été numéro 1
mondiale chez les chez les amateurs et
et elle est en progression elle aussi
constante et donc ce serait merveilleux
qu'on puisse avoir ces deux joueuses là
parce que sont deux joueuses qui sont
absolument certain mais pour le golf
français ce sont deux excellentes
ambassadrices Alexandra vous la
connaissez Pauline oui je la connais un
petit peu pas aussi bien que c'est une
petite différence d'âge mais je trouve
qu'elle serait très complémentaire en
fait parce que Pauline adore le show et
un événement comme les Jeux Olympiques
je pense qu'elle pourrait se sublimer
encore plus et ça pourrait créer du coup
les deux faces de la joueuse
professionnelle une un peu plus ouverte
l'autre un peu plus réservé mais qui
vont toutes les deux très bien performer
et il faut aussi rappeler quand même que
les tournois qualificatifs pour ces Jeux
Olympiques c'est sur une période de deux
ans en fait donc là ça commençait en
juin 2022 donc là il y a que une toute
petite partie qui s'est écoulée mais le
principal est à venir donc ça se trouve
il y a une joueuse du lait qui va tout
soudainement éclore et remporter
plusieurs victoires et finalement
devancer une joueuse qui évoluerait aux
États-Unis
pour l'instant non pas tout à fait
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de Pauline
à vous Philippe moi je connais moins
bien Pauline je connais un peu plus
Perrine un peu parce qu'effectivement
elle s'entraîner chez nous elle a passé
les
j'aimerais bien avoir Perrine Pauline
j'aimerais bien
et Pauline bien évidemment Pauline c'est
vrai comme le dit Alexandra cette c'est
une jeune joueuse qui est
ultra dynamique qui est de ce que
j'entends présent et donc voilà donc je
souhaite d'être là effectivement en 2024
Pauline alors je les connais pas
personnellement
elle elle est très présente sur les
réseaux etc on sent tout le plaisir
qu'elle a dans ce qu'elle fait et puis
le point commun avec Céline je pense
c'est travailleuse donc on a des
joueuses voilà qui ont de l'ambition qui
font ce qu'il faut pour atteindre leurs
objectifs c'est à dire qu'elle bosse
comme dans tous les sports si on bosse
pas il y a pas de miracle elle travaille
elles ont envie de réussir donc on leur
souhaite le meilleur et ça ferait une
très belle équipe de France aux Jeux
Olympiques dernier favori chez les
garçons Victor Perez il a 30 ans c'est
un golfeur moderne il a gagné des
tournois sur le Tour et la participer à
des majeurs et ce qui sera aux Jeux
Olympiques normalement selon toute
vraisemblance oui
oui
parce que le réseau un genre moderne on
peut le dire il t'intéresse il a
démontré qu'il était capable de gagner
ce qui est très très important c'est pas
simplement de faire de bonnes
performances mais aussi d'avoir cette
capacité à gagner et que ce soit en toi
ou Victor ils ont aussi démontré cette
capacité à gagner maintenant ce serait
bien que à l'image de Céline voilà il se
rapproche des meilleurs joueurs du monde
parce que autrement c'est ce que on peut
toujours gagner mais on va faire de la
figuration aux Jeux olympiques et pour
pouvoir avoir une vraie chance de
médaille il faut faire partie des 20
meilleurs joueurs du temps Perez voulait
vous apprécié Alexandra il était pas à
Tokyo là je pense que il méritent tout à
fait sa place
après
le site
je pense que c'est un parcours qu'il
faut avoir voilà qu'il faut connaître
avoir joué plusieurs fois après bon la
plupart des joueurs on joue et le jour
pendant l'Open de France certains vont
jouer pendant la Ryder Cup
mais oui après c'est c'est un peu comme
on le disait tout à l'heure Victor c'est
quelqu'un de un petit peu plus discret
également et je pense que il est en tout
cas le niveau pour être là pour gagner
je sais pas mais en tout cas le niveau
pour être là Perez avis partagé moi je
trouve que il bon signe théoriquement
quand même chez golfeur français taper
Victor
il allait pas mal mais Victor Perez oui
c'est en l'image qui donne c'est
celle-là celle d'un garçon sérieux aussi
qui travaille qui qui se donne les
moyens de réussir ça gagne en régularité
il y a pas de raison qu'il soit pas là
quoi maintenant je vais vous proposer
une une liste d'outsiders pour ces Jeux
Olympiques on va commencer par Alexander
Lévy la 32 ans il a atteint en 2018 il a
46e place mondiale très rapidement il
peut y être oui ou non là
malheureusement il a eu des blessures là
il se remet il va pouvoir rejouer dès
pas la semaine prochaine mais dans 15
jours donc oui je pense qu'il doit avoir
très très envie parce que il est resté
sans jouer pendant un petit moment vous
y croyez c'est un excellent joueur et
l'envie peut être un moteur là le fait
de pouvoir enfin revenir il peut être
très motivé et nous créer une belle
surprise il connaît bien le Golf
National de 50 ans Philippe
Alexandra
Alexander levier et donc lui c'est sûr
que la passion pour un événement comme
ça elle serait au maximum il y a un
garçon un petit peu plus jeune Romain un
langage qu'il a 27 ans il a joué le
master soduggustin en 2016 qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez aussi peu prétendre à
être au jeu en tout cas lui a dit très
clairement que cette année il voulait
que ça puisse être une grande année je
pense qu'il va mettre les moyens pour
pour y arriver et il a un potentiel
énorme il a fait partie des meilleurs
joueurs du monde quand il était amateur
il faut savoir
à l'époque où il était amateur il a le
même âge que dechambault et il était
devant de Chambeau
donc le potentiel maintenant ce qu'il
faut c'est que les choses se mettent en
place et que et que il y ait des
résultats qui sortent un autre golfeur
que j'adore Victor Dubuisson il a 32 ans
il a été numéro 1 mondial en amateur en
2009 il a joué une Ryder Cup il a
atteint la 17e place mondiale Victor
buisson Philippe pilateau
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez j'adore le
joueur Victor c'est un joueur incroyable
c'est c'est il est capable de voilà de
sortir du golf comme comme les meilleurs
joueurs du monde à un moment donné donc
être là et en tout cas le niveau pour
être là gagner s'il est s'il est dans
une bonne semaine il est en capacité en
capacité effectivement de repartir de
repartir avec une médaille oui tout à
fait alors le courtier il a le talent
dans les mains très clairement après ce
qu'il a envie de jouer ce qu'il a envie
de pêcher voilà ça dépend des semaines
mais il a il a le talent très très
clairement et je pense qu'on est plein
de français de fans de golf qui aimerait
le voir présent au plus haut niveau
international il faut rappeler qu'il a
déjà joué en rider Cup qu'il a gagné des
tournois devant Tiger Wood enfin il a
brillé au plus haut niveau sur la scène
internationale du Golfe c'est quand même
pas rien
il faut qu'il ait envie c'est tout on a
beaucoup parlé d'envie et chez tous ces
joueurs et joueuses il faut qu'il ait
envie mais le talent et les capacités
techniques je crois qu'il les a une fois
encore je suis pas coach je suis pas un
expert parce qu'on l'a vu faire nous
démontre que quand même il est capable
de faire des trucs pas mal Alexandra
victoire du Buisson vous êtes fan aussi
j'imagine en gros tempérament
français connu à l'étranger en fait si
on demande à un américain au milieu du
Texas s'il connaît un joueur un golfeur
français si jamais il connaît quelqu'un
ce sera Victor du 800 en fait et donc
c'est comme demander à un français non
golfeur de citer un golfeur il va citer
Tiger Wood c'est bien sûr pas la même
échelle mais vraiment en terme de
propriétés c'est différent et mais
j'écoutais récemment un podcast avec
Olivier l'église qui fut apparemment de
manière très éphémère son entraîneur
normalement c'est plutôt du Colombier
mais il disait qu'il y avait rien à
faire en fait c'était plus de confirmer
lui donner confiance mais au final il
avait peu de choses à lui transmettre
tellement il avait face à lui un cas
assez extraordinaire enfin il y a
Mathieu Pavon il a 30 ans il a fait le
très beau résultat dernièrement est-ce
que lui aussi à peu prétendre à une
place votre avis il est place son vote
cher on a l'impression encore quand
quand vous entend parce que j'ai eu la
chance de jouer avec lui le tournoi de
des 2000 links pardon et
moi j'étais impressionné par la qualité
de sa frappe c'est un garçon qui qui
travaille beaucoup qui est bien dans sa
peau et je pense que lui aussi toutes
les chances de pouvoir faire partie de
cette équipe Alexandra vous êtes
d'accord oui oui tout à fait on a
vraiment il y a 6 7 personnes
pour y être donc ça ne devrait pouvoir
tirer que tout ça vers le haut tant
mieux alors on va terminer par un quiz
sur le golf aux Jeux Olympiques le
fameux en latisé depuis tout à l'heure
il est enfin là ce quiz on va voir si
vous êtes très fort fort ou on va voir
ou pas on va voir dans cette table
attention à Philippe à laisser gagner
Pascal
Ier
sur Alexandra
alors première question quand le golf
a-t-il fait son entrée au jeu olympiques
est-ce que vous savez vous pouvez
l'écrire allez-y comme ça il y a pas de
triche ne copiez pas sur votre voisin
alors
montrez-le ok alors 1924 soit Arnaud
courtier 1900 pour Philippe Pilato 1904
pour Pascal Griso et 1900 pour Alexandra
Bonetti et bien la réponse est on va la
voir
1900 aux Jeux olympiques de Paris voilà
politique
alors deuxième question il y en a il y
en a 8 ans je le précise à golf combien
de nations participantes aux JO de 19
et je peux vous dire qu'en rédaction il
y a quelqu'un qui l'avait trouvé du
premier coup en golf bien sûr
le golf a fait son entrée donc aux Jeux
Olympiques
en 19 combien de nations il y avait
c'est bon je dirais 17 histoire
25 pour vous 18 Alexandra 6 pour vous
Philippe et pour 17 et bien la réponse
est on va la voir 4 nations encore
Philippe pilateau qui est là alors je
vais mettre je vais mettre les bons donc
Philippe il attend deux points
alors
troisième question quand le golf a-t-il
été retiré des Jeux Olympiques après une
première apparition en 1900
alors 1908 pour vous Philippe c'est ça
1904 Alexandra 1904 Pascal et 1904 et
ben on va voir la réponse
réponse c'est
on va la voir normalement dans un
instant
1904 bravo voilà
on va passer à la question numéro 4
quand le golf a-t-il fait son grand
retour au jeu olympiques c'est peut-être
la question la plus simple
[Musique]
bon vous avez tous raison on va avoir la
réponse à Rio en 2016 je mets un point
pour tout le monde on va passer spatial
la question 5
combien de nations participantes aux JO
de 2016 c'est peut-être la question la
plus dure
ce sera plus normal combien de nations
participantes aux JO de 2016 alors
partons sur un champ de joueur c'est
énorme et qui vous avez 5 secondes
bien mettre un chiffre mais moi je me
filer la pression 2016 en 2016
70 tout compris
75 pour Pascal 30 pour Alexandra et 70
pour Arnaud courtier on va voir la
réponse
41 41 nations qui étaient le plus proche
du coup
[Musique]
attention
et Philippe Pilato alors qui est le
vainqueur masculin des JO de 2016
alors on va voir la réponse
et oui Justin rose Grande-Bretagne on va
mettre un point pour tout le monde
attention Alexandra et Philippe sont à
égalité
avant dernière question qui a gagné chez
les filles aux JO de 2020
par contre pour le coup on va voir la
réponse
et bien oui c'est l'américaine alors on
va mettre un point attention attention
dernière question est-ce que Alexandra
va prendre le dessus sur Philippe aux
Philippe sur Alexandra on va voir dans
quelques instants la dernière question
qui a remporté le plus de médailles d'or
parmi les nations participantes
au total Jeux Olympiques qui a remporté
le plus de médailles d'or parmi en golf
bien sûr
alors États-Unis pour Arnaud courtier
Grande-Bretagne pour Pascal Griso
États-Unis pour Alexandra Bonetti et
donc un pour la Grande-Bretagne du coup
et bien on va voir la réponse dans un
instant la réponse s'affiche les USA
avec 5 médailles d'or et 13 médailles
donc et bien Alexandra Bonetti remporte
la victoire en porte ce quiz bravo
Alexandra
Philippe a fait un peu exprès sur la fin
je pense
alors c'est déjà à la fin de cette
émission on va terminer ceci on parlait
sport spécial Jeux Olympiques par une
citation de l'immense champion américain
Jack niclos le défi du golf c'est
d'accepter d'être imparfait je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]